we're so excited about the the next film
we have coming out it is called Zootopia
to tell you about Zootopia I'd like to
bring out the filmmakers of Zootopia
ladies and gentlemen the director who
directed tangled and bolt mr. Byron
Howard the director of record Ralph and
from The Simpsons rich Moore and the
producer of wreckit-ralph and bolt mr.
Clark Spencer the producers Judy Hopps
is someone I think you all know from a
great great television show once upon a
time Jennifer Goodway
[Applause]
hi Jennifer Jennifer remember you got
the card I am NOT a Disney fan though I
am a Disney addict she's crazy
does he know he's crazy obsessive we're
all family here what do you think about
playing Judy Hopps
I didn't feel about that the dream come
true it's it's as exciting as it gets
she is a bunny from the burrows she is
on the outside of town she moves to the
big city of Zootopia to follow her
dreams and become the first bunny pop
with Zootopia Police Department that's
pretty good
that's pretty good I like your dreams I
like the voicing the character of
gazelle in the film and singing an
original song it's an amazing person
somebody who had the great pleasure to
get to know over the past couple of
years and she wanted to extend a special
message to all of you so ladies and
gentlemen Shakira
[Applause]
and I'm so happy to announce that I
might be a part of the new Disney movie
Zootopia where many play Israel she
plays this great character gazelle which
represents all of the ideals of Zootopia
that truly anyone can be anything and
her song try everything launches hops
into her journey into the city
you